the 2012 post-election headlines told
the story of President Obama's tech and
data team victory and the Republicans
failure if you want to support our party
Republican officials and most
importantly their donors wasted little
time demanding the resources and the
talent to match Democrats tech savvy and
avoid a repeat into 2014 midterms inter
Chuck to fail behind me is the team of
parabellum labs we have not only of the
people who work with our data who
aggregate it and make sure that do the
quality control but we also have the
data scientists the people who are
actually building models off of that
data inside the RNC's retooled national
headquarters chuck de feo is overseeing
a new model for a political party's
efforts to streamline the massive
amounts of voter data he's working with
17 million dollars more than 40
full-time staffers in Washington and
Silicon Valley and a recruiting effort
that has reached the top engineering
schools in the country as well as from
Facebook and LinkedIn we're making the
right investments to to make sure that
they had that our campaigns have the
data they need they have the predictive
analytics that they need the feyo's team
is building a platform designed to
streamline the reams of voter
information coming in from social media
email and consumer data from that
parabellum plans to develop and utilize
constantly evolving sets of apps that
can be sent straight to the field to
pollster efforts to target voters and
donors so then God meet chief data
officer as areas Retta he points to
Republican David Jolly's recent special
election victory in Florida is a
positive indicator for the team's
direction we're taking what we rooted in
Florida and basically expanding upon him
multiplying upon it on a national scale
Jolly's victory served as a sort of beta
test for the RNC's data platform
operatives from across the party had
access to the real-time data collected
or purchased from vendors including
information from your home or car
purchases we can observe a lot of that
passively which allows us to be at scale
at a very low cost in other words the
RNC thinks parabellum can match the
Obama 2012 data mining systems and
improve on them working on good yeah
it's going awesome and how do you gauge
right now numbers-wise what you guys
have done that's been successful so
again goes back to the question on the
wall does this drive data and all
does this get us more information about
a voter is it helping us to put them on
a path to vote for our candidates more
likely to volunteer for our campaigns
and eventually may become a donor still
Republicans are relieved not to have to
take Obama's team head on this time
around when you no longer have the
imperative of getting an incumbent
president reelected you have you have a
little bit of a brain drain a less sense
of urgency I think we've got a
significant opportunity to win in 2015